alright let's shift all together let's
do it let's talk about the stuff you
really know how about that ok
biology evolutionary biology I thought
this would be an interesting place to
start you just recently did a talk with
Richard Dawkins just in the last couple
weeks as I understand the video of it
should be up online somewhat soon I am
told it will be up within a couple of
weeks ok so hopefully people will be
able to actually watch this conversation
very quickly this event was put together
by Pangburn philosophy there's been a
little tumult around that and I know you
just wanted to quickly address what's
going on there
yeah so Pangburn philosophy was
obviously imploded and that has left
people speculating about what happened
and why some of us like myself continued
to participate with an Byrne just very
quickly for people that have no idea
they were putting together a lot of the
public events that included well the one
that you moderated with jordan peterson
and sam harris in vancouver also the one
that Douglas Murray moderated which I
think was that in the UK or is that
Australia one in Dublin and one in
London yeah and then a series of other
events like the one that you did with
Dawkins and this this day of reflection
that was supposed to happen on November
17th that we all pulled out of which now
I think you can take it from there
sure so let me just say that I know that
there's a lot of speculation about what
took place why people pulled out of the
New York event why some of us like
myself stayed in and I was in at the
point that it was canceled a couple days
ago
and I I do hope people will recognize
that there was a predicament for those
of us like like myself and like Eric who
were looking at the the Pangburn
situation and trying to figure out what
to do which was at the point that
Pangburn canceled the Auckland event
something new emerged so other events
had been canceled but there had always
been refunds for people who had bought
tickets at the point he canceled the
Auckland event there was
a lack of refund money which called our
attention to the fact that something was
off money that should have been kept
separately for that event so that if it
was cancelled it could have all been
refunded somehow wasn't if we didn't
know and and to be clear you guys and I
think not just you guys hadn't been paid
for some previous things too so it
wasn't just about the people that were
buying the tickets just oh I wasn't
allowed in Auckland it was Sydney yeah
Sydney is where speakers as far as I
know that's where speakers didn't get
paid for the first time and certainly
one of the people who didn't get paid
and still haven't been anyway yeah and
also as a sidebar that's so that is why
I pulled out of the day of reflection
thing in New York I was supposed to host
the whole day but then when I realized
that people hadn't been paid for
previous things and I had heard through
the grapevine that there was some shady
stuff going on I just said you know what
let me just not get involved in this
mess and that's right which makes
perfect sense yeah so I think what I did
also makes perfect sense which is I
looked at the situation and I said well
you've got people who haven't been
refunded their money for Auckland you
got speakers from Sydney who haven't
been paid and if the New York event
comes apart then it's going to compound
that it's going to create new ticket
holders who haven't been paid and so my
thought was let's have an event that
gives people what they paid for so that
we don't make the damage worse and I
certainly didn't sign up for anything
new after the Auckland event was
cancelled and there was a failure to
repay patrons but my thought was from
the point of view of protecting the fan
base from whatever was going on behind
the scenes at Pangburn the the better
part of valor was to make the event
happen and be successful rather than
create another Auckland situation so in
any case that you know and I should also
point out that up until so Pangburn gave
us a little bit of warning just a couple
days before he cancelled it he said he
was about to cancel it and Eric and I
tried to save it in fact Eric who had
pulled out of the event quietly so as
not to
he and I got on the phone with Travis
and we tried to get Travis to agree to
hold the event and to let us rescue it
we offered to work for free yeah we
would have liked to have held the event
so that it wouldn't cause further harm
to people and I don't know why Travis
refused but he did so anyway it got
cancelled and I I just I do want people
to understand that it was not that
anybody was unaware that something was
going on the question was what's best
for the fan base the movement to the
extent that there is a movement is it
better to have another event canceled
and have more harm I didn't think so
yeah and I know this is all a little
insider baseball for people so I know
you just wanted to get that out so I'm
glad that it is a few of us also we had
discussed possibly doing a free thing
and who knows maybe there will be
something in the future if people end up
getting stiffed on take your prices cuz
obviously we want people to get
something and if we can all figure it
out
we will okay so that being said you did
do an event with Richard Dawkins as we
said the video should be up soon enough
Chicago what should we expect from this
and I think on its face I think a lot of
people would say wait a minute well
we've got Weinstein and Dawkins these
guys should agree on everything
shouldn't they well this goes back to
the question of what happened to
evolutionary biology 30 years ago and
Dawkins and I do agree on a tremendous
amount but the place at which we start
disagreeing I think is the branching
point where you have the way
evolutionary theory went thirty years
ago and the way it should have gone and
you know that's not an indictment in of
self field's take wrong turns all the
time but what should happen is you
should detect that you're on the wrong
path because suddenly progress ceases
and that didn't happen so so what
actually happened 30 years ago that God
well that ironically
I would argue that the the last
piece of progress that we all really
agree now there's been lots of empirical
work but the last piece of theoretical
progress actually involves Dawkins
Selfish Gene we essentially encapsulates
a synthesis that does lots of things
including brings a proper theory of
cultural evolution online which cultural
evolution is a non-issue for almost all
creatures but for birds and mammals it's
a big deal and for human beings it is
new to the big deal so to the extent
that we did not have a way of discussing
cultural evolution prior to the selfish
gene Dawkins introduction of the concept
of memes which have now been trivialized
by you know people putting funny
captions on pictures but the concept of
I think you could argue they've become
the most relevant way of communication
in a bizarre way yes but they become you
know little tidbits come little bites
the fact is almost everything about
human beings that is interesting and
special at least touches cultural
evolution if not is entirely housed
there so in order to understand
ourselves we have to get this cultural
evolution things straight and Dawkins
set us I believe on the right path
chapter 11 he introduces the word meme
he introduces the concept he sets us in
motion but he makes an error in that
chapter no big deal
we all make errors but it hasn't been
corrected in 30 years and so so so what
is that error the error is in a Mis
portrayal of the relationship between
culture and its evolutionary units and
genes and the way that they evolve so
what Dawkins says in that chapter is
that memes the units of cultural
evolution exist in a new primeval soup
right he says this is a new kind of
evolution it begins at the point that
culture begins to happen and it is
independent of the genes mm-hmm that
cannot be the case it cannot be the case
because the only reason that you are
able to pick up units of cultural
evolution is because you have a brain
that your gene
created which is hospitable to those
things which means that to the extent
that your culture starts wasting the
time and the energy and the resources of
your genes the genes are in a perfect
position to shut it down right so my
point to Dawkins on stage in Chicago was
that can't be right and if you make an
adjustment to the theory that you
Dawkins presented in 1976 if you adjust
it correctly you discover that many
things that are paradoxical about
cultural evolution are no longer
paradoxical and many things about human
beings are suddenly tractable so can you
give me an example of that I can give
you the ultimate example I will accept
that so the ultimate example has to do
with religion and things that function
like it so if you think about you know
this is the antithesis of some little
picture with a caption on it right you
imagine Catholicism for example
Catholicism is a set of beliefs that has
profound implications on the way that
believers deploy their efforts their
resources the things that they elevate
the things that they issue all of that
so the question is why right
so Dawkins and I would agree there is no
supernatural explanation necessary to
interpret what is taking place on earth
or anywhere else in the universe you
don't need a supernatural explanation if
you are trying to explain phenomena so
why is it that people who hold a belief
that supernatural forces are at the
heart of human affairs why are those
people so successful historically that's
the question and Dawkins and I disagree
with it I would disagree over it because
a he has this view of what cultural
evolution is that it's independent of
genes I say it is actually much more
flexible than genes but
subordinate to the the will of the genes
and he also does not subscribe actually
he came around a bit on this on stage I
thought but he also does not subscribe
to a a lineage level interpretation of
selection he is a traditional kin
selection estat the individual that the
gene and the individual are the the
places that we must interpret evolution
and if you do that then lots of things
are paradoxical hard to explain may be
intractable if you accept that lineages
evolved that adaptation can apply to the
lineage then you can begin to understand
phenomena like religious traditions as
adaptive properties of a population and
there's tremendous progress to be made
so what happened on stage with Dawkins
was at dinner prior to the event we more
or less agreed that I would lead the
discussion because I had a sense of
where we disagreed and he would react to
it I put together a list of points on
which I was certain that we agreed
points on which I was pretty sure we
disagreed and points on which I wasn't
sure which way to call it which we
didn't get to mm-hmm but anyway I
started out by pointing out the vast
agreement between the two of us and
asked him about each one and more or
less I had been right about where we
agreed and then I started to go through
the list of places that we disagree and
I thought it was a fascinating
conversation it was definitely closer to
the conversation I hoped we would have
than one I feared we might have there
was a lot of progress could you could
you sense which way not that this
matters in the grand scheme of things
but at us at some level it does which
way the audience was going not that it
not that it is about who gets more
cheers or anything but what I do find
fascinating about these things and
although I didn't attend any of the live
events with Sam and Jordan you know I've
watched some of them and just sort of
note
a little bit of crowd applause and jeers
and pauses and things I think gives you
some extra taste that maybe for you guys
on stage you can't quite quantify well I
mean first of all I'm a believer in that
and it was one of the most important
tools that I used to use in the
classroom you know figuring out what
people heard how it landed what they
don't yet have
so anyway I'm very cognizant of what
people are hearing and I was listening
carefully to to the audience and you
know the thing was set in motion you
know has another new atheist event and
so in some sense I was I was battling
uphill because my basic point was new
atheism is is a cul-de-sac it's it's a
problem in and of itself it's a problem
because at the end at the end of it
there isn't enough is that like the most
simplistic way that I could present it
no I mean let me just put it in the
stark term yeah okay
atheism is defensible but new atheism is
wrong and new atheism is wrong because
yet portrays religious belief as a
defect of mind rather than an adaptation
a non-literal adaptation and so in a
room full of people who you know Dawkins
is a very famous person people
presumably showed up to here yeah
Dawkins almost all of those people have
at least deep sympathies with the ideas
of new atheism and so somebody setting
out to say actually new atheism is an
incorrect instantiation of atheism
because it is effectively ideological
and it accuses people who have religious
faith of being mentally defective and in
fact Dawkins and I tangled over this you
know I said look you're you've called
religion a mind virus mm-hmm that's an
incorrect interpretation and at first he
said well I don't really mean anything
deep by virus he said it's you know you
could argue that every gene in the
genome is like a virus right and I said
well but what people hear when you say
that is that
that they're mentally ill for believing
this and he said well they are mentally
ill right and so you know you could see
the division in his own thinking right
because they're at that point he's then
saying both things at same he was saying
both things and I you know I understand
his position about you could interpret
each gene as independent sure you know I
could defend that position too but in
order for there to be an honorable
atheism we have to own up to what all
that religious belief was about and then
I mean and this is a place that I get
into an easier pickle but a pickle with
Peterson as well is the question of if
we acknowledge that religious belief is
adaptive then all of the things that are
true of adaptive phenomena kick in and
the most important one is that adaptive
phenomena are not timeless they are
adaptive relative to a historical time
and place and it may be a very
long-standing time and place but the
point is there is nothing it is purely
magical thinking to imagine that
religious traditions that are thousands
of years old are the core of the toolkit
for moving forward our existence in 2018
is so novel that if there's one thing we
can be sure of its that our adaptive
nature is a poor match for it so then
can anything be truly timeless is is
that the right question well yeah yeah
but the way you do it is this the longer
standing some truth of some kind is the
closer it gets to being timeless in
other words if we look at things that
are very evolutionarily long-standing
well those things have persisted through
environments that were very different
from each other so what that means is
that thread still functions irrespective
to an extent of the context the longer
it lasts the more likely it is to speak
to truths that continue to be relevant
but the the bitter pill for modern
people with respect to understanding the
degree
to which evolution is the key to seeing
ourselves properly is that we live in
circumstances that are more novel than
almost any creature has ever faced now
you know a creature can you know fish
can flop into a boat and it's suddenly a
novel circumstances and it's dated
minutes right don't tell that to the
dinosaurs in the meteor was coming right
well there you go that was so novel that
you know I mean dinosaurs did survive
that yeah one group the birds yeah
they're still with us and they're doing
great but we are creatures living in
circumstances that are not only novel at
an unprecedented level but are changing
so rapidly that even to the extent that
we can figure out what to do the world
changes out from under us we have to
stop that right that is going to kill us
that if you want to know what the
greatest existential threat to humanity
is it is the rate of change that we have
set in motion which makes it impossible
for us to adapt fast enough to it it has
to be slowed down to a point that we can
catch up is that impossible though
because we already have that power
because I'm with you on this just from
my limited knowledge of this just from
what I do you know from doing these
shows and that people can watch more you
know the amount of information that you
can intake on a given day the amount of
things that you can share you can speed
things up and listen to them two times
as fast you can clip everything and that
we can take all this information things
can be live-streamed like all of this
bang bang bang bang bang bang bang it's
happening faster we're learning more we
know there's a great thirst for this but
can it be slowed down I mean what what
force could slow down progress really
wisdom and that that's the that's the
problem is that wise yeah thank you we
are children in this landscape and
children grow up right I mean the key to
raising children properly is to is to
back off the things that protect them
enough that they actually get burned
without being burned so severely that
crippled in other words you have to
experience the places that your notions
are naive in order to become last night
we are now in a situation in which we
are behaving in a childlike fashion in
you know in a very you know in a foundry
or something like that right we're like
children running around in the foundry
there's molten metal that we need to you
know figure out how to recognize it how
not that all right we're just pressing
every button going
yeah we're just like that baby buttons
are cool there's power yeah we got to
stop doing that I don't think you know
if I'm to be candid about it I don't
think we are in an unrecoverable
situation I can see the path forward and
it's it's all still plausible as far as
I know but I'm worried that we won't get
there and the reason we won't get there
is that there are lots of things that
have been true that just aren't true
anymore in other words the people who
are in love with you know a limitless
market in which you can do anything that
you can manage and it's all cool and
then at the point we find out that it
isn't cool we might have to take some
action but in the meantime you know
you're free to explore I'm very
sympathetic to this view as you know
well I would be sympathetic to this view
if I didn't recognize that there was a
problem in which all for example if you
look at the way our economic system is
hooked up to our political system
there's a problem where anytime you set
a new force in motion in the market if
that force pays at a high rate in the
short term but it costs at a high rate
in the long term by the time you get
around to discovering the costs in the
long term it has found its way into the
political system so that it cannot be
reversed you can't have a system in
which you can't reverse things so this
way the simplest way to frame this would
be some sort of crony capitalism kind of
thing right well you know what we're not
we're not truly free market because
we've politicized a competition
basically well you know I try to look at
everything through an evolutionary lens
and to me politics and economics are
just one more landscape and they're
interesting because it's humans and
humans are especially capable in this
regard but
the the natural tendency for a creature
that has found its way into a niche is
to protect its access to that niche and
the way creatures do that is they freeze
other creatures out so there is this
natural pattern and I mean I can't not
see it now that I now that I've
understood that it exists this natural
pattern where the upstarts who succeed
the stories that we know we don't know
about the upstarts that failed mostly
but the upstarts that succeed end up
tremendously powerful and then they go
through this process in which they
become hostile to up starkness and they
become hostile to up starkness for the
most natural of reasons which is that
their well-being depends on shutting
down the process through which they
became successful so this could be like
Facebook buying all their competitors
and things of that nature
it's the let's put it this way there are
obvious versions and then there are
innumerable versions that are cryptic
mm-hmm and we're never going to
understand the whole landscape of ways
in which those who have reached this
level of power that you and I will only
dream about that they will then shut
down the access to others it's like
there's a I don't even want to call it a
conspiracy because it doesn't happen to
have any consciousness to it at all but
there is a tendency for for those who
have succeeded to shut down the
mechanisms through which they sixty I
mean you can see this with people
frequently remarking on the fact that
immigrants are often not that wildly
enthusiastic about further immigration
mmm-hmm why is that
for obvious reasons you know you're
talking about do people who've just
entered at the bottom of the economic
ladder want more competition well
they're actually there's a tension
between what people should want that you
shouldn't imagine that there's some
immigrant nests that necessarily has you
favorable to anybody else who has that
label does this also sort of explain a
little bit of what's happening in the
tech world right now in terms of it
seems that these companies Twitter
Facebook YouTube are potentially at
least using algorithms against their own
audience
shadow banning people I mean that
they're basically now turning against
their own people because of their that
whatever they perceive to be their own
protection or long-term health even
though I would probably argue in those
cases that's not really what's gonna
happen oh I mean
without question this is what's going on
and let's put it this way if you're at
the top if you're in that strata you
have a lot to lose through anything you
can't predict and so there is a way in
which we expect the upstart who got
there through some sort of radical
transformation to be favorable
throughout a radical transformation but
the way we should understand it is that
once you've gotten there radical
transformation becomes threatening and
you start see it's a conservative
evolutionary force and you know you can
look at what Twitter is playing with
these days with potentially eliminating
like some follower counts you know at a
breathtaking act of paternalism yeah you
know at best and they're doing it for us
for us right because we shouldn't be so
concerned about paying attention but
really the truth is as much as we all
recognize that there's a problem with
you know tweeting to get trivial likes
on the other hand understanding what
your audience hears what they find
favorable what doesn't ring true to them
is the way you learn it's the way you
steer and so effectively Twitter is
playing with blinding us so that yeah we
can say whatever we want into the void
but we have no idea how it land
there's no paying the back to you basis
right and so you know I mean I don't
need to tell you you're a comic stand in
front of the room and you get a lot
better with my laughs yeah better it's
better when they laugh yeah exactly
yeah what should we be think you know
what before I get to that so as you know
I was just in in Europe and I did a
bunch of the Scandinavian and Nordic
countries and Sweden was a particularly
interesting case because I know that our
fifth most viewed country for this show
is Sweden which is sort of fascinating
could
how tiny Sweden is so I had sort of
circled that we did two shows in Sweden
I had kind of circled them on the
calendar because I was like something's
going on in Sweden I want to figure out
what it is
now I thought if you would have asked me
before I did the show that first night I
thought it was gonna have a lot to do
with immigration
what I realized although there were a
lot of questions about immigration at
the end it had much more to do with
gender and what is happening to their
highly egalitarian society that have
done most of the things related to
gender and true equality correctly for
many many years and all of our friends
on the left always point to Sweden and
Norway and Finland these countries that
I was just added as the examples of
their perfect societies and they're
really struggling with certain things
that you know that the government's
forcing them to have genderless
kindergardens and that the emasculation
of men and the removal of the father and
that they have supposedly Europe's first
feminist government and all of these
things so I thought as long as I have
you here and since gender seems to be
such an endlessly provocative and also
misunderstood topic what should we do on
gender right now yeah well beyond you
going to Sweden and figure out what's
going on there something well what it
struck me as is that they've done
everything right in effect in terms of
egalitarianism and they've done it for
four decades now they've done it right
and when they got to the end which is
now when they got to the current day
they realize that despite all of this
equality men and women are still
different that women still care more
about people and men still care more
about things so even though they've been
given the exact same opportunity women
are still becoming nurses and men are
still becoming engineers and it's like
the the social justice warriors or
whatever you want to call that crew they
still don't like the results of true
equality so I think that's why Sweden's
in such a weird place the average person
is like what we've done it right we did
it right everyone's equal you can do
whatever we want but then the result
isn't being allowed to be accepted does
that does that make some sense oh it
makes perfect sense I'm in fact right I
think the
the naive left finds the failure of its
hypothesis absolutely galling and so
they're effectively trying to erase that
failure by hard-coding the solution into
government so I think that's exactly
what's happening in Sweden right now and
it's tragic and with respect to sex and
gender it is so needless right the fact
is the truth of sex and gender is there
are parts of it we don't fully
understand yet but in general actually
we do we pretty much understand how we
got here and the truth is it is
asymmetrical it is complementary the
truth of male and female is a
complementary truth it may be largely
irrelevant in the present in other words
technology has eliminated most of the
basis on which the division of labor
between men and women
initially evolved so I think we have
actually an opportunity here to become
to behave in an enlightened fashion but
the easiest place to solve this problem
is sex and gender what we should do is
pretty clear and it is not hard to
ground an evolutionary theory because
unlike other places like race for
example we do know what to think with
respect to sex and gender mm-hmm and the
basic outline is this men and women are
different for historical reasons the
basis for that difference and the
utility of that difference has largely
been neutralized by the modern world we
don't need to retain those distinctions
but some of those distinctions are built
in at a deeper level than others so
meaning you could potentially be a
stay-at-home dad and that could be
perfectly fine but that probably for
evolutionary reasons is not going to be
the thing that usually happens right
but here's here would be my point we can
democratize access to almost everything
with respect to sex and gender there are
very few places where we actually
need to have some asymmetry and access
but probably you know the firefighter
who comes into the burning building
through the roof to pull you out when
you're panicking you know you don't know
what to do because you've never been in
a fire before on average that should
probably be a guy they're just better
built for it if there's a woman who is
well enough able to do it should you you
know be picky about the firefighter who
plucks you out of the bra don't
absolutely not I mean you know I
personally am thrilled to see it every
time it runs against the narrative that
we expect right you know I I'm very fond
of Stacy Brown the the police chief had
evergreen who was driven out along with
Heather and me I thought it was great
that she was a female and that you know
she was a an excellent cop so I'm I'm up
for the narrative being broken by by by
reality as often as possible but you
democratize the access but you don't
force people to do what they otherwise
would for one thing you wouldn't even
want to force it because for every job
that you would you know force women into
it some higher rate let's say
engineering jobs because it sounds like
a good thing to do there's some awful
job that men are disproportionately
represented in that you would also have
to force them to be fair so you
democratize the access you recognize
that the division of labor that we have
that we have inherited is largely
outdated but you don't override people's
choice you know if women if you
democratize access to engineering
perfectly and women go into it at equal
rates great if they don't that's cool
too so in any case it's it's a question
of allowing Liberty to decide where
people go after you've done away with
unnecessary barriers well it's so
interesting because I think then you hit
it right on the head that well Sweden's
now politicizing it they're making a
point of making this political because
they will not accept the science of what
they've done correctly and I think that
that is what is what has led the sort of
average person
there to go this is this is just not
right so it's I don't know what the way
out is I know I sense that most of the
people there didn't know what the way
out was well I mean the way out really
is to recognize that the the ire of the
authoritarian left on this point is
actually indicative of the whole problem
in other words because sex and gender is
more or less clear the desire to erase
it irrespective of the collateral damage
is an indicator of just how wrong this
path is so you know I find this all the
time where people have if you're not
focused on biology and you're focused on
the world that you find and you're
galled by by inequality then you think
well let's just solve the inequality
which is hard code the solution but then
you hard code the solution and it says
men and women are the same to the extent
that there's any difference in what they
choose to do that's the result of either
cryptic barriers or internalized
misogyny or whatever right and then the
problem is you're now interfering with
my biology club right you're now telling
me that we that the received wisdom is
that men and women are the same thing
when I know damn well that can't be
right
so you don't want to build a solution
that forces you to confront your
biologists your physicists your
statisticians right you want all of
these stories to the extent that they're
true have to reconcile all true stories
reconcile to the extent that you've got
a naive notion over here and you want to
just write it in because it seems very
important to you and you're willing to
tolerate all of the cascading effects
elsewhere you don't belong in a position
of power unfortunately though a lot of
those people are in a position of power
and I think we're seeing more of them
get into positions of power and I think
it's also how now having a counter
effect in Europe which is why we're
seeing the rise of more far-right
parties because people are just like
screw this this is so wrong I'm gonna
take my chances over here people who
inherently are not safe are right or
certainly not racist are now playing
with people that perhaps they would
played with before because they're so
sick of this and I and I'm worried where
that leads us oh I think I think this is
exactly I've heard you say this is that
you are afraid that the the lunacy over
on the authoritarian left is actually
going to you know its collapse is going
to leave people who otherwise wouldn't
play ball with the far right yeah over
there and not because they're racist
that's the key to this it's not that
they'll suddenly become wake up and be
racist or hate women or a gays but it
will be such a disgust of reality and a
rejection of what's provable that
they're gonna be like at least there's
something over here I mean it's it's an
awful bargain but I think it is I think
it I just think it is I see this
frequently where people you know because
they detect that there's something wrong
with communism and socialism are often
driven right pretty far into the let's
not regulate anything camp and the
answer is actually we have to regulate
stuff just add a desire to continue as a
species so you know I don't want to see
people driven because there's something
wrong over here I don't want people to
be driven into into a reactionary
position that is not justified the thing
on sex and gender though is maybe this
is the key question every reasonable
person who just simply observes the
world knows that men and women are not
the same thing they know that those
differences have an implication for the
way we view all sorts of things like
mating and dating what careers we want
to have how we view risk and all of
these things for historical reasons all
reasonable people can infer that from
just their own observations of the world
you are now confronted with people who
insist that you not acknowledge what you
can see mm-hmm those people are crazy
right they're dangerously out of control
they are dangerously out of control on
other topics where it's harder to know
what's true mm-hmm but you wouldn't want
people who were so naive as to argue
that men and women are effectively
identical but for oppression in charge
of any policy you don't
the man charged of economic policy in
charge of you know prisons anything so
having seen just how far their confusion
goes can we all agree to shut them out
of the discussion about how power is to
be wheeled today and the rest of us can
have a discussion about what our values
are what we think we know what we don't
yet know and what its implications are
that that's the place we should go that
seems like an effective ending here
unless you want to throw in one more did
we not hit something that's been
rattling around in your brain actually
no I covered a lot of territory yeah all
right well it's always a pleasure
sitting down yeah and you joined me last
night for stand up in Brea California
this will be up already but you're
joining me tonight in Oxnard I'm turning
you into a stand-up comic which is a
biologist's worst nightmare no no it's
it's not quite the thing where you're
the lead singer of your favorite band
has laryngitis yeah but it's about as
close as I could hope to come yeah all
right well we're gonna do this will do
well we did it about a year ago after
the original one but we'll do this more
than once a year because you're you're
right in the center of all the things
that I think are right at the moment and
for more on Brett follow him on Twitter
as long as they can track how many
followers he as at Brett Weinstein
[Music]